yeah they started off 11 for 17.
really struggled from three in the
second half but the game was already
decided as
anthony davis gets the first hoop
offensive rebound davis
the size so important for the lakers
they out rebounded miami
by 18 in game one butler gets in the
paint
blocked by howard picked up by danny
green
green back to james james charges down a
lane goes inside and easily lays it up
and in
get out of my way says lebron james with
the left hand and then
lebron james
[Applause]
powering his way to the rim lakers up
six
early olynyk passing sides stolen by
danny green
james left open has plenty of time and
knocks down the three the first
three-pointer for the lakers after
missing the first five
alex poster this is the best player on
the floor and we let him step in rhythm
a practice shot
nobody even chase him down and try to
contest it lebron james will knock that
shot down
and make some pay for the memphis
grizzlies also with that
talented basketball team that had great
success alex caruso has come in
feet inside an easy two for davis as
lebron james gets his third assist
point laker lead those are under a
minute to go
anthony davis again and it just
again perfect they're a team that
has kind of surprised a lot of people
throughout these playoffs james
three-pointer that's good before the
season began the miami heat
the oddsmakers had them to make the
finals 75-1
after being over three the other night
james drives hard bank shot good count
it and the foul
lebron james with a chance for a
three-point play lakers go up a dozen
and it's like lebron is saying i
remember the last time you defended me
in the finals
i know your work limited defensively
limited on the backboard but can
function offensively
rondo nice feed inside the only flaw
that you you can
point to in his game is he's got to
improve defensively
beautiful pass rondo to james count it
and one
rajon rondo with the perfect alley-oop
lakers back up by a dozen job by the
lakers lebron james gets on the back
side
of the zone and rondo delivers the
basketball on point
that's just eye contact and making them
play rondo was
he was terrific in game one big part of
that turnaround when
laker finds howard shot clock down to
three james gonna have to drive put one
up quickly gets in the paint
throws it up shut rolls around and drops
through
[Music]
anthony davis guarded by leonard a
little
sidestep his perimeter jump shot
is calling for it again as the big
height advantage on crowder
shoots over him knocks it down anthony
davis
nine of 10 from the field the lead is
back to 15.
this is good defense crowder just
too small more shoot more a couple of
times he's done that even though he's
been struggling so far in these finals
they need his three-point weapon
davis tries again anthony davis lighting
it up
robinson got caught between
who he was close to close to and anthony
game four he had a 30.12 rebound game
has hardly played again only the second
game of these playoffs as davis puts it
in
anthony davis deuce and how about
anthony davis
putting his stamp only missed one shot
all poked away james picks it up
james down elaine runs into robinson
count it and the foul
in transition season angle
that's a weak attempt for an offensive
foul
a terrific rookie from kentucky but his
team's still down by 16
james the floater 19 points for lebron
james
these are very limited caldwell pope
on the follow anthony davis
forwards into the back line to try to
take
away some of these size differences
brian james and anthony davis i don't
care who's on the other side of the
floor
they give me a chance to win every
single night
oh anthony davis does it again
absolutely incredible for two games thus
far
i don't know if the heat have an answer
for them
nights he scores a lot of his points
from the free-throw line he was 10 for
10 in game one
as kuzma misses gets another offensive
rebound puts it back up and in
the domination continues 30 huge points
flat out getting it done offensively
on the offensive board stellar finish
mama
there goes that man first shot attempt
was blocked
he's got 17 points 10 assists lebron
james
knocks down the three
lebron james drives can't finish davis
on the follow
shot misses ball tipped up and in i
think it was james who got it
it was james without dragach without
adebayo
davis caldwell pope inside the james and
an easy two for lebron james
including lebron and anthony davis on
the back line
against the zone you're overmatched very
nice
james throws it up top to rondo
rondo inside to james falling away
jumpers good
31 for lebron james the lead is up to 13
as we're under three to play
16th offensive rebound caruso inside
davis for the slam
back up to 13 under two minutes to play
caruso great job of driving the seams
and dropping it off to davis
[Applause]
16 points eight assists rondo inside to
james james
scoops it up and in 33 for lebron james
hey lebron mike trudell in l.a i i
believe you would have just
finished your junior year in high school
uh 2002 kobe and shaq
both go for 30 plus against the nets
game three the finals
uh you of course are then drafted next
year unad
is the first time lakers team uh lakers
teammates have done that since then
just wondered if you were like your
thoughts on the kobe shack dynamic and
kind of what it's like
going through a game like today with ad
um especially at a similar level
of efficiency um you know obviously
being in high school and watching the
kobe shack
um duo it was the most dominant duo that
i have personally seen in my life from a
basketball perspective
hadn't seen obviously we knew the force
that uh shaq brought to the table but
the elegance and force that kobe played
with as well
they were very dominant in what they did
on the floor on both sides of the floor
so to be in a conversation with those
two guys
myself and anthony myself and a.d he
would
he's going to kill me myself and a.d
it's just very humbling because uh i
mean i know i grew up watching those
guys
i grew up with myron kobe obviously for
you know
a kid coming straight out of high school
so you know admired that
kid that was young and got the
opportunity and and obviously the force
that shaq played with so
i'm just just very humbling and i'm
happy that we
we can be even mentioned with those
greats anthony uh you and lebron
a.d lebron are the first laker teammates
to score 30 plus in a finals game since
kobe and shaq did it in
2002. i asked lebron the same question
are there elements
that you see of both kobe's game and
shaq's game
in your game and both kobe's game and
shaq's game and lebron's game
and if there are could you describe them
um you know those two guys are
awfully special
they do all special together you know
the best duo we've seen
uh multiple championships
but they both were so dominant um
i know they had a little sit down they
was talking about their argument because
they both
want to be so dominant they both want to
be great they both want to win and
that's why they
kind of jailed together outside of
everything else that
you might have heard that you know they
were going through um but
you know those two guys were selfless
you know they both had a competitive
spirit
with themselves to to build their teams
to win
and i think you know me and braun is the
same way you know we're two guys who
want to win
um no matter the circumstance you know
we both want to
yeah we both want to uh you know to make
sure that
uh we do whatever it takes to help our
team win
and you know when you got two guys
that's selfless and you know you know
it's not
always be you know pretty um
you know sometimes we're going to argue
sometimes you know we're going to have
disagreements but
we know it's coming from the right place
but when you have two guys who
who you know want to win as bad as we do
and want to be dominated every single
game
you have games like you know tonight you
know we're two guys you know able to
score basketball with a rebound
um unable to find guys so um it's rare
you see it
uh we know we have something special
with us too and with this team
and we just try to you know capitalize
on it
match up the pair you guys and them
who uh who's shaq and who's kobe out of
you and lebron
um he's colby because he handles the
ball and i'm shocked that i played him
folks